the birth of any new member of an
endangered species is a cause for
celebration but the arrival of a baby
rhino in San Diego has implications not
just for his own kind but for an even
rarer breed only two northern white
rhinos are left in the world but now a
special delivery is giving renewed hope
for their survival John Blackstone has
the story
this scampering calf is named Edward he
and his mom Victoria are southern white
rhinos a distant relative of the
northern white Johnny capira was the
lead Rhino keeper they do have behaviors
that are quite like a pup feeding that
tail just wags and it makes us feel like
he's really just happy to be alive and
happy to be here no one is happier than
Barbara Durant the zoo's director of
reproductive science Edward is the very
first baby Rhino born in North America
using artificial insemination and frozen
sperm this reproductive technology is
well established in humans now why such
a challenge rhinos the techniques that
we're developing are difficult because
they don't understand the complexities
of her reproductive cycle and her
reproductive Anatomy is very complicated
to decipher the Rhinos reproductive
system keepers trained Victoria to walk
into a chute and to stand for
ultrasounds that led to a successful
artificial insemination assisted
reproduction is the only way to save the
northern whites it's a big step in the
overall plan which is to help the
northern white rhino come back from the
brink of extinction the hope is southern
whites will eventually become surrogate
mothers for northern white embryos
creating those embryos depends on
futuristic science taking place in the
saree parks frozen zoo the largest gene
Bank in the world with samples from some
10,000 animals including northern whites
thus far they've transformed Rhino skin
cells into stem cells a stem cell is a
cell that has the potential to become
any other cell in the body and the
eventual goal is to redirect them all
the way to sperm and
they've succeeded in turning stem cells
into beating cardiac muscle that makes
up part of a heart well creating sperm
and eggs is likely years away
they have impregnated another southern
white Durant says the arrival of one
more healthy baby will be a cause for
celebration because doing something one
time doesn't prove that you can do it we
want to make this technique of
artificial reproduction routine and
reliable the artificial insemination
takes about 20 minutes but the gestation
takes some 16 to 18 months this is a
long-term commitment for Durant and it's
personal the Safari Park cared-for NOLA
a northern white female until her death
in 2015 we feel a responsibility as a
member of the species that caused their
extinction for CBS this morning Saturday
John Blackstone Escondido California I
cannot get enough we adopt a baby Wow
we know you love it at mo Rhino Geoff
speeding got it hey